i always forget the embracer owns
gearbox which they bought for 1.3
billion yeah and they got all of this
from square for 300 mil yeah that is i
don't know
like i said if that based on numbers
alone it just feels like square was like
please just take them just get them away
from us i have the statement from
business wire
the transaction will assist the company
in adapting to the changes underway in
the global business environment
by establishing a more efficient
allocation of resources blah blah blah
accelerating growth in the digital
entertainment domain
enables the launch of new businesses by
moving forward with investments in
fields including blockchain ai and the
cloud
absolutely not
square enix has sold some of its key
studios and properties to the embracer
group but just who are the embracer
group and what does this mean for square
games like tomb raider deus ex and
legacy of
who are kane
showing it
you oh okay uh so joining me is uh
hussein hi keith legacy of kane number
one legacy of kane fan take that skill
up and uh everyone else
so 300 million us dollars um not a lot
not a lot of money for square to sell
off eidos montreal crystal dynamics
square nx montreal um as well as major
ips like tomb raider deus ex thief
legacy of kane and quote more than 50
back catalogue i want to thank you for
saying legacy of kane is a major ip
still i appreciate that everyone
involved i feel like i wouldn't get out
of this recording alive if i didn't um
what do you make of the 300 million
it feels very very
low
considering
the other acquisitions that are
happening now um and and kind of the
numbers that are attached to mobile
developers and sales like that it feels
incredibly low and i don't know
how this has happened but uh i guess it
speaks to like due diligence would have
been done people would have been looking
at the markets people would have been
looking at libraries and what's being
sold and this is what they came to
it feels a bit almost like squaring so
like just just get taken
just just have them we we don't we don't
care just get them out of here
which is a shame because um a lot of
amazing properties and a lot of amazing
talent gone there yeah um to the
embracer group which is the kind of a
current black void of of like um
properties companies ips and that kind
of stuff yeah it is massive the embracer
group has huge scrooge mcduck energy and
um yeah we're still waiting for like
some sort of clarity on what this means
for
those those uh properties and those
teams well rumors have been swirling for
a long time about square and potential
acquisitions over there um it i feel
like it's a bit weird because some
properties like life is strange
outriders and just cause
are staying with square enix yeah
whereas
everything else including tomb raider
which has kind of been at least in the
west the most recognizable might not
have done so well sales wise as square
enix japan has frequently
said which is kind of awkward so you can
kind of see there is that rift between
square west and square japan like
japan basically shits on
the uh the every time like a game comes
out in the west in japan is just like
well it didn't live up to expectations
didn't live up to expectations whereas i
wonder if it's because they're judging
against games like final fantasy xiv
you just make a ton of money i also
they're judging against games like final
fantasy 14 and they're also judging
against similar games in those genres
from other studios which isn't
always the case like
i imagine they're looking at uncharted
and being like why is tomb raider not
selling like uncharted yeah and there's
a whole lot behind why that is the case
um and it is extends to many many things
ranging from you know pedigree of
developer marketing and also like
relevance now and first of that kind of
stuff but i don't know there's a there's
there's a
there is a habit of like um undervaluing
and also like making these comparisons
in ways that are skewing your perception
of how they work yeah and how they
perform um yeah i i
it's such a shame to see
it is also baffling to see which ones
they pick to keep and which ones they
sent on their way and it makes me feel
like oh they see potential in outriders
and just cause i'm like you don't see
that potential in tomb raider they also
did say like the square enix collective
stuff is what they want to keep
their focus on alongside their own
japanese titles so it could be that you
know the uh um
those games fall under that banner now
and they'll have a small group of uh
western appropriate games um that are
they're kind of like they're still
betting on and just cause does have a
little more of the um just cause sales
yeah it sells it has wider appeal as
well as an open world game and also the
team behind it has a lot of
built in history with making games that
are increasingly relevant as a format
everyone is trying to make open world
games now and they're and and
a lot of them are like using complicated
physics systems and that kind of stuff
and the team behind um avalanche behind
uh just cause has been doing that for
years so at the very least they're best
positioned to
put out another major open world title
and it functioned well and it'd be well
received and do pretty well especially
given that just cause has been away for
a little while as well
um i'm not sure what the bet on
outriders is
um it did well
um i mean it did it was a i feel like it
was a flash in the pan though because it
went in game pass yes so game pass
helped it a lot but perhaps they see
future potential in outriders um it
could simply be as simple as someone
looking at a spreadsheet and going like
well this did good once we just need to
invest deeper into it and and it will be
better whereas they see tomb raider
going from a sharp incline into like a
decline with the latest one which was
not as well received um as the first two
in the rebooted series
um so who knows what the thinking is
behind it but it is a baffling set of
kind of like decisions made
you could i mean you could say that
about square
like western stuff for the past 10 years
or so a baffling decision yeah i feel
like the idos part of square um or when
they merged and and that kind of stuff
was
was
continuously mismanaged i would say and
they had they didn't know what to do
they had no idea what to do with it and
they had a few breakouts like the tomb
raider stuff was pretty great um and
releasing thief uh was it just after
dishonest dishonored yeah and and it
kind of like got buried um and they made
some
decent bets as well that paid off like
um
uh guardians of the galaxy
is a good game yeah um it's got one of
the most annoying voiced characters in
the history of video games within rocket
but it's still a good game like the
story was really good a lot of
creativity yeah and the writing is
fantastic but um yeah that was a good
avengers lesson i was gonna i was gonna
say are we talking about the marvel
elephant in the room here because
avengers is i mean even guardians which
i really enjoyed did not move the needle
really dramatically and avengers has
kind of become this game that like
it comes up every so often because
people are like look at the steam
concurrence on avengers that's the only
time avengers is coming out as someone
who played a lot of avengers um you
really did i play i played an alarming
amount of avengers um it for the longest
time
has felt like a game hanging on for dear
life yeah and it still very much feels
it feels like that and i feel like now
this is a good
kind of breaking point or like a
an opportunity for either the embracer
group or screenings to be like okay
we're done here this is the end and
they've got a good reason to do that i
mean they can be like you know we had
the acquisition like we've had to
reassess what we're doing we think that
the team is better off you know working
with um
because crystal dynamics is
co-developing perfect dark alongside the
initiative which is something that is
going to remain in in uh as a
partnership and in active development
they've got a good reason to be like we
got a we've got to pull away from this
this um well crystal's now a three-game
studio yeah along with um co-developing
perfect dark they're working on the new
tomb raider the announcement of which in
hindsight is in incredibly suspicious
because it's it's kind of like the
um the old bethesda move of announcing
starfield and elder scrolls 6 the year
before an acquisition um kind of trying
to juice that price up maybe that's
speculation on my part but you know
announcing a new tomb raider game um at
the latest unreal event but they also do
have an ongoing commitment to avengers
um embraces said
currently published games would move
over after the deal but future games
would require working out a deal with
the license holders so
as of right now we don't know if we're
gonna get that
extra avengers content or if we're even
gonna get a sequel to guardians we'll
get whatever
was agreed upon when they were part of
square enix
um which
i don't know if they i
i think spider-man is out now
i believe
uh i think the wakanda expansion came
out that's all uh she-hulk the next one
she-hulk should be the next one i
believe so if that was if that deal was
already inked then great i don't suspect
we'll get any more beyond the the
current crop we
if we want a sequel to guardians of the
galaxy that's going to have to be a new
agreement between the embracer group
and
um
the
marvel as the rights holder
uh yeah but it's just a
a weird state but like i i fully i fully
believe that
the avengers game is not long for this
world yeah um well you mentioned the
embracer group in ominous tones there
they are the kind of ones that whenever
talk about acquisitions gets thrown
around people automatically go oh sony's
acquiring or microsoft's acquiring or
tencent is requiring whereas embracer
has been hoovering up all these
properties
in europe in europe
and so now once this deal closes it
means that this will be uh most of their
development talent will be in the us and
number two country will be canada
they'll have over 14 000 employees 10
000 devs 120
internal studios more than 230 games in
development over 30
aaa titles so
i always forget that embracer owns
gearbox which they bought for 1.3
billion yeah and they got all of this
from square for 300 mil yeah that is i
don't know
like i said if that based on numbers
alone it just feels like square was like
please just take them just get them away
from us
um which is
unfortunate as we said but yeah the
embracer group
it's kind of like quietly becoming a bit
of a behemoth
um
especially given that it was born from
the ashes of thq
which is kind of interesting because we
all saw how that that there's that meme
of the the person like hitting the small
domino and at the end is that the big
one and i saw one which was like um
and the very small the some very small
one was like thq bets too big on uh you
draw tablets and at the end of it was
like yeah like embrace the group owns
square enix's biggest properties and
it's just like holy crap you're right
yeah um but yeah it is a
it's it's got it's one of those weird
like i said describe it as a black hole
where a lot of companies a lot of
developers a lot of ips go into it and
then they're never seen again for a
really long time like but then they've
had like they have clutch media they
have those they have showcases where
they show off but they don't have like a
kind of one big showcase for everything
they they're still kind of diversifying
a little bit they have asmody as well
they have um
dark horse
media so they bought comment finally
finally something we can get some good
comics based on
on our video game properties um but yeah
then they have vertigo games you know
they have a lot of stuff there
it just feels like this is this weird
kind of incubation period before they
can come out i mean like the the
interesting thing about embracer is that
it's kind of
it's kind of unnerving to see a lot of
these big companies a big properties
that we love go into like i said this
void of
like collection someone's private
collection of ips
but it's also if you think about it from
a glass half full approach
it's actually quite exciting
because square enix
had properties like deus ex they had
tomb raider they had legacy of kane and
they were doing nothing with it and they
showed no intention to do anything with
it and they also don't have the
capability to do anything with it given
the given the kind of uh resources they
had the teams they had it wasn't likely
that they were going to put an internal
studio on a new legacy of kane game
right because crystal dynamics is busy
with other things they're making
avengers they're making
another tomb raider game the likelihood
of them making a new legacy of kane game
is not is not super high and also we've
seen that they're not super good at
courting talent from outside um its own
internal studios people can fly with
outriders is one of the few exceptions i
can't think of that many that
have happened beyond them and have had
some kind of level of notoriety i mean
uh well i would say deck nine but i feel
like deck 9
you know they they rose to notoriety
with life is strange life is strange and
then square enix came along well no so
no don't nod
don't not and and square brought life is
strange but then you know they gave the
ip like they purchased it and they've
given it to deck 9. so deck 9 has that
kind of like yeah sorry what i mean is
um like the property itself came along
and that was what they bet in like they
knew that they had something good with
life is strange and they were like we
can take this to a developer whereas the
idea of resurrecting a property like the
legacy of kane and going out there and
being like who wants to make a legacy of
cane game it's not happening whereas
with the embracer group you you have
this either you have a crap ton of
internal developers that are like hey
we've got this ip now as part of our
family can we make a game based on it or
they're in a position where they're like
we just bought a bunch of properties now
let's put these properties to work and
they're like if anyone has pitches for
legacy of cane
come to us that's way more likely
because they have like i said there are
this behemoth that has more resources
than square enix um had and they have an
actual
reason to invest in new properties to
make good on their money um spent on it
which is not a lot whereas square enix
is like we're not going to spend money
we can put on final fantasy on trying to
bring back this vampire game that yeah
tamora and skill up love
it's like whatever
um well i mean let's talk about a square
so obviously we mentioned earlier like
rumors
have been flying for a while about
square um and like i said the japanese
side of the business has kind of always
said that the western side has been
underperforming
and um
so now
i have the statement from business wire
the transaction will assist the company
in adapting to the changes underway in
the global business environment
by establishing a more efficient
allocation of resources
accelerating growth in the digital
entertainment domain
enables the launch of new businesses by
moving forward with investments in
fields including blockchain ai and the
cloud
absolutely not ai and the cloud yeah and
cloud's great um blockchain i i mean
like who knows where wherever the
intention behind this is
you know
is real like right now i feel like if
anyone sells anything the way you stop
people from panicking after you've sold
it is like
just mention the word blockchain
and and
like investors and anyone who's like got
money in a company will be like oh okay
this is the thing that's appropriate and
is like current so who knows whether
they actually want to get into
blockchain i wouldn't be surprised if
they did but i would just be just as
there would be a lack of surprise also
if they were like no
we just said that so that our share
prices don't tank or whatever it is yeah
i mean if that bubble's going to burst
yeah but i mean
it's not like square japan is um
clamoring around four titles you know
they've announced
kingdom hearts for they're on the
blockchain let's go
yes sora shoes are in the blockchain
that's why he's got small feet now uh
you know we've got seven remake part two
although we haven't heard about that in
a long time but we have heard about
final fantasy 16 which is apparently
nearing completion of development or is
closer to the end than people think it
is so i don't know it's such a
weird one yeah square enix um
i think if this manifests in anywhere is
going to be they've got quite a robust
mobile business which is oh yeah isn't
there a seven battle royale yeah there's
a there's a soldier
battle royale game and there's a final
fantasy 7 battle royale game and there's
a bunch of all the pixel remastered
they've got pixel remasters but also
outside of you know the western world in
in japan i believe they've got a few
titles that perform pretty well i mean
like yeah they have that mobile division
um or that mobile understanding where
you could conceivably see them um
working in blockchain and cloud and ai
stuff which is like okay that's fine um
it feels like
they overall
for me like it feels like this is a
thing which they said to kind of stop
panic and stop people from being like oh
they're just selling off everything um
it definitely will it's a fire safe yeah
yeah fire sailing i feel like the intent
behind them is we know what is making us
money
and we need to focus on that and those
things are our internal japan studios
um which is basically final fantasy
kingdom hearts dragon quest
let's focus in on that the mobile title
is attached to it
force spoken
oh yeah i guess still exists which is
technically a
i don't know what kind of collaboration
that gets gets kind of like um put under
but it's a little bit of west a little
bit of east um but they have that and
then i think that their whole thing was
like tightening up the bootstraps and
like focusing on that so they can
start to reap the benefits of that
without having losses in and like
expenditure on things that aren't
actively making them money
um so and then the kind of like
blockchain ai stuff is something they'll
look into
probably to some degree but also serves
as a good way to stop people from
getting nervous if they have you know
investments tied up in square enix and
and stop also like from partners from
you know from being like what are you
guys that's the most word isn't it god
help them though if they tie any
blockchain stuff to your square enix
account
that screenix account is basically like
the most
impenetrable thing ever like if you want
to ever secure some data hide it in a
square enix account because you will not
be able to log into it the next time you
try it that's how it works
i've the amount of times i've had to
make a new account for final fantasy and
it's just been like
into your one-time password and i'm like
okay what is it you know good luck
figuring it
out um
well then big news uh do you i mean
let's let's end on do you think square
enix japan is up for sale now i wouldn't
be surprised i mean there's been some
rumors about screenings japan coming
along and and that going up um for sale
i would
the thing about these companies is
they're always up for sale
like and there are always people
interested in it it is like
it's not a moment where someone suddenly
goes hey you know what would be cool why
don't we buy square enix you know it's
better than one development studio
company yeah a billion companies like
obviously sony is the is the name that
most people are throwing around as the
most likely to be interested in it
the way this works is sony is always
interested in it yeah and sony has
people at playstation has people on
their team that are actively and always
assessing what acquisitions they can
make and if they look at square enix and
like not now they'll come back within a
few months time to look at it again so
right now whether the intention is there
or not or whether it's going to happen
there are probably playstation people
looking at square enix and being like
can we do this should we do this and
they are likely making some offers as
well in all likelihood because that's
the way the the world works like you're
always someone's always trying to buy
you out um i wouldn't be surprised if
sony came along and were like we're
buying you um and they could make a good
case for it as well because one they've
got a long lineage with playstation and
also they can just roll up and be like
hey
we have an inbuilt audience for final
fantasy we always have you know we made
final fantasy as big as it was based on
our platforms and it makes sense for us
to combine et cetera et cetera and then
also sony as they mentioned previously
is
looking to get into more like um
long-term revenue streams and have like
games as a service titles and final
fantasy
xiv is like one of the biggest right now
so it makes perfect sense for them to
roll up with a big dump truck of money
and just be like you you belong to us
now um
so i wouldn't be surprised if that
happens um i don't think it's going to
happen immediately like we're not going
to hear about it for a little bit i
suspect i think the dust is going to
sell i believe i think like you know
when this deal with embracer goes
through which is meant to be through
july through september they're hoping to
finalize
then maybe someone will make that yeah
sony will need to take a little bit of
time to kind of let the dust set or see
what the worth is and then do it um in
the same way that microsoft did with
activision there was a reason why
why that played out the way it did
because they were like
now your stock is uh not doing great so
we can bite you for cheaper um so there
will be people being like let's wait see
what happens after this embrace of stuff
give it a few moms i don't know a few
weeks whatever it may be and be like now
is a good time to do it or let's wait
let's see what happens
and then that happens you know what fair
play to them it would make sense i
i don't want one company to own
everything
but also i would like to see companies
thrive and if sony comes along and
they're like hey we can make final
fantasy even better
okay cool like that's great and for me
like number one hope now is that like
embracer is is talking to people about
bringing back franchises like deus ex
especially legacy of kane i have been on
goals i'm gonna say my uh yeah my ad
advocacy for legacy of cain's return has
been long many many years in the making
um so i'm hoping that someone rolls up
and it's like let us make that yeah well
i guess we'll just have to wait and see
and find out
hopefully um well thank you everyone for
watching it's so weird that i'm having
to look past you i'm sorry tam but
thanks for watching we'll have all the
latest as and when it comes through keep
your eyes peeled at game spot
new studio
podcast studio